all right in the wake of this tragic
school shooting in Florida President
Trump is showing some very strong
leadership he's now trying to find ways
to keep America's schools safe our kids
safe and during another White House
listening session earlier today the
president he offered up ideas and
solutions let's take a listen to what he
had to say we have to harden our schools
not so for the moment a gun-free zone to
a killer or somebody that wants to be a
killer that's like going in for the ice
cream
that's like here I am take me we have to
get smart on gun-free zones when they
see it says this is a gun-free zone that
means that nobody has a gun except them
nobody's going to be shooting bullets in
the other direction and they see that as
such a beautiful target they live for
gun-free zones I think a concealed
permit for having teachers and letting
people know that there are people in the
building with gun you won't have in my
opinion you want to have these shootings
because these people are cowards they're
not going to walk into a school if 20%
of the teachers have guns it may be 10
percent or maybe 40 percent and what I'd
recommend doing is the people that do
carry we give them a bonus we give them
a little bit of a bonus but the NRA is
ready to do things and you know people
like to blame them and they do have
power and all of that but they want to
do they wanted they they actually came
up with certain of the rules and
regulations that we have that but we're
gonna have to toughen that I told them I
said we're gonna have to toughen them up
we really do have to have offensive
measures also I know people don't like
talking about it but we need offensive
as well as defensive we have to be
totally defensive but if we don't have
offensive measures within these schools
we're just you're just kidding yourself
spokes alright you have to give the
president a lot of credit because
instead of engaging in the same old
tired back-and-forth repeating the same
talking points the politicians the media
use after these tragedies he's actually
trying to come up with solutions solving
the problem now here's the bottom line
we have a choice in all of this do we
keep having the exact same political
debate that we've had ongoing since
Columbine that's not going to change
anybody's minds what do we actually fix
the problem do we want to protect our
children now remember after 9/11 well we
fixed the problem of aircraft security
and I'm as strong I am a very strong
supporter of the Second Amendment and
I'm sure people in this room are as well
tonight predictably the left and the
liberal media that are talking about
getting rid of the Second Amendment our
compasses are talking about confiscating
guns like Australia for a minute let's
take politics out of all of this let's
just focus on the issue how do we keep
our kids safe in school now the
president's saying he wants solutions
and that's why he sat down with students
and parents and teachers and governors
and state and local officials now he
talked and he listened and by the way he
wants to have a positive impact this is
a simple truth the left and the media
can talk all they want about banning
certain types of weapons used by these
evil maniacs but the thing is you could
never stop the evil that exists in some
people's hearts and if you take away and
you ban one weapon these killers those
with evil intent will use something else
we have already seen this happen let's
go back to the Virginia Tech shooting
the deadliest shooting in the history of
this country and in that case the
shooter use pistols and what the left
the media cannot seem to comprehend or
don't want to comprehend is that evil
exists in this world there are murderers
they are rapists there are child
molesters there is evil and by the way
if they don't use a rifle in the case of
these these school shootings then it's
going to end up being a hand gun the
next time and then after that if it's
not a hand gun it's going to be another
type of weapon or tool remember the
Boston bombers they used explosives that
were made from everyday products that
are readily available other terrorists
have used trucks vans and cars others
have used knives we got to ban
everything and as much as the left and
the media want to think that the
government can fully stop these killers
with regulations and laws they cannot
because people that have this evil they
will always find a way
cause pain and suffering and inflict
maximum carnage the only thing that
comes with banning weapons is that you
will infringe on the rights of
constitutional law abiding American
citizens that have the right to protect
themselves and their families what's
missing are real solutions to protect
these innocent kids you know speakers at
the White House let's in this listening
session they brought up a lot of great
ideas and solutions that we've been
discussing on this show in the case of
the Florida school shooting there were
warning signs all over the place about
Nicholas Cruz we knew that he was
mentally ill we knew he was unstable we
knew he was capable of doing something
the students all seem to know it and the
same goes for the teachers there were
reports that police were actually called
to Cruz's home 39 times over a
seven-year period that's a pretty good
indicator Cruz got into trouble at
school he threatened students he wasn't
allowed to carry a backpack at the
school and he was eventually expelled
from the school the Miami Herald reports
that school officials actually sent out
an email warning teachers about Nicholas
Cruz and then of course you have his
social media footprint had pictures with
guns and knives and all kinds of
disturbing photos then of course the FBI
they were called and warned specifically
twice about Nicholas Cruz and they did
not follow up now in other words every
bit of evidence to indicate that this
was going to happen was right there in
front of us people saw something said
something and nothing happened they did
nothing and we're also learning two new
disturbing pieces of information tonight
and according to that report the school
security cameras were on a nearly half
hour delay which slowed down law
enforcement and their ability to capture
Nicholas Cruz and the Broward County
Sheriff is saying that the armed
security officer on the school's campus
didn't even enter the building when the
shooting was taking place and instead
the officer took a defensive position
outside of the school this is why we
need solutions we need ideas we need to
fix the problem we need to protect our
kids and here's the thing we already
know what works and there are things
that we use every day
office buildings in airports in
courthouses and other government
buildings and other facilities the key
if you want to solve the problem of
security and it's not really that hard
every school in this country needs to
have a comprehensive threat assessment
that can be done by retired or former
police or retired former military
special ops these schools are soft
targets we need to harden the perimeters
around these schools and for those of
you worried about the cost really we're
going to really be cheap when it comes
to defending our kids because I also
guarantee you these former officers and
veterans they would line up and
volunteer to help their community to
keep our kids safe now these assessments
need to include ways to secure the
perimeter control every point of entry
and from there if these experts
determine that it's needed you need to
put an ID system in place zero
exceptions they need to know everybody
that goes into that school I work it in
two office buildings in New York one for
radio one for TV if you don't have a
work ID you are not allowed entry
visitors are vetted through a security
system and you must show your ID and
then you usually checked in case you
have any metal objects going in and from
there on a case-by-case basis if some
schools need it they should have metal
detectors and other security measures
and finally you have to have an armed
security presence at every school in
America and you can hire right
retired veterans and police officers
schools can no longer be soft targets
you have to have people there who can
fight back and challenge and confront
any potential threat and when you think
about the statistic that was brought up
at the White House listening session
yesterday
the average shooting school shooting
lasts only three minutes it takes police
on average six to eight minutes to
respond which by the way is incredibly
fast but why not have somebody already
on the scene that is armed that is
trained and ready to respond and save
lives at a moment's notice we take
potential security threats against
politicians look at the security at the
Oscars for these prima donna celebrities
at the red carpet they have every ounce
of security you could ever dream of why
wouldn't we do the same thing for our
children and in addition right and in
addition to all of that we also need a
much better way to identify and help
these kids that are obviously in trouble
there has to be a system put in place to
spot kids that we think are disturbed we
need to help them get them the help that
they need and we have to put a focus on
social media whether it's someone
physically monitoring it or easier that
somebody reports what's going on in the
case of this particular kid Nicholas
Cruz now also on this stage earlier
today the NRA CEO executive vice
president Wayne LaPierre he was here at
CPAC he delivered a fiery response to
liberals in the media that are trying to
blame his organization for what happened
in Florida Lapierre also challenged them
to do more to protect schools and to
protect our kids here's what he said
Chris Murphy Nancy Pelosi and more
cheered on by the national media eager
to blame the NRA and call for even more
government control
they hate the NRA they hate the Second
Amendment
they hate individual freedom in the rush
of calls for more government they've
also revealed them true selves
the elites don't care not one whit about
America's school system and school
children it's a bizarre fact that in
this country our jewelry stores all over
this country are more important than our
children our banks our airports our NBA
games our NFL games our office buildings
our movie stars our politicians they're
all more protected than our children at
school does that make any sense
now when Lapierre right good points you
also pointed out how the NRA has
actually led the effort in many ways to
keep guns out of the hands of criminals
and from people that shouldn't have
these weapons but of course if you're
watching
well the corrupt media in this country
listening to Democrats in Washington
didn't ever tell you that because
they're only interested in demonizing
attacking the NRA the Second Amendment
supporters it is all predictable and it
is all pathetic for example you have to
all you have to do is look at what's
happened during fake news cnn's gun
control quote town hall last night facts
differing opinions didn't matter
CNN stacked the deck against Second
Amendment supporters just take a look
Dana lash will join us in a minute at
how she was treated last night let me
answer the question you can shout me
down when I'm finished but let me answer
in this question
they spoke about that before the
president made a move and they spoke
about that before Attorney General Jeff
Sessions made an announcement about that
too so that answers there is your
question with that second though and and
I understand you're standing up for the
NRA and I understand that's what you're
supposed to do but you just told this
group of people that you are standing up
for them you're not standing up for them
we had three lawmakers on this stage and
only one of them hinted at reinforcing
the background check system it is only
as good as the records submitted to it
only one of them even got anywhere close
to mentioning that we have to have more
than 38 states submit records that's
number one number two we have to develop
better protocol to follow up on red
flags now Dana will be here in just a
second and also you've heard people
actually saying burn her Wow now think
about that how can anybody have a
serious conversation when one side is
literally calling the other side
murderers and screaming that they need
to be burned
now fake news CNN they're not interested
in solutions this was all about creating
political theater as a matter of fact it
did nothing to solve the problem now
fake news CNN also has another very
serious problem on their hands cotton
hey he's a Stoneman Douglas high school
student and he actually saved lives
during this shooting and he's reporting
that CNN actually tried to script his
questions at last night's Town Hall that
he didn't end up participating in
because he wasn't going to be a part of
that farce here's what that student told
her own Tucker Carlson earlier tonight I
just want to make sure I have this
straight so you sent them a long in
effect essay on what you thought but
they did they put his own words in the
question and they weren't the same as
the words you would send and they were
the producers words
absolutely they had taken what I had
wrote and what I had briefed on and
talked about and they actually wrote the
question for me but not with your words
I mean they put their own words into
your question even after after they'd
asked you to send questions in but that
seems dishonest ah it definitely did and
that's kind of why I didn't go last
night
originally I had thought that it was
going to be more of my own questioning
to my own say and then it turned out to
be more of just a script and she had
actually said that over the phone that I
needed to stick to the script so the
students saying that
fake news scripted his questions and
what do you call them and they're saying
they never provide script questions and
the Colton's father withdrew his name
for participating before the show began
but this is not the first time that the
fake news network has been accused of
scripting questions Michelle Malkin put
out a great article back in January of
2016 for the New York Post here's the
headline cnn's long history of allowing
Democratic Town Hall plants and here are
just a couple of the many examples she
found 2007 CNN YouTube debate I've
quoted undecided voters literally
included a member of the LGBT Americans
for Hillary Clinton steering committee a
John Edwards supporter that asked
questions about abortion a log cabin
Republican that was really backing
Barack Obama a concerned mother that was
a union activist for United Steelworkers
that had endorsed John Edwards and a
former intern for Democratic
congresswoman Jane Harman and we know
that the former DNC chair former CNN
contributor Donna Brazile leaked Town
Hall questions to the Clinton campaign
so they had an advantage over Bernie
Sanders in that case